[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we all know people like these former
neighbors
old friends relatives
there are so many of them so many
chronically ill and aged in this country
almost 6 million influence
[Music]
many of them without ordinary and often
vitally needed
dental care
fortunately more and more attention is
now being focused on their plight
and dentists are discovering that the
principal difference between routine
treatment
and invalid treatment lies in the
management of the patient
dentists experience shows that treatment
of the home bound and infirm
requires no highly specialized training
and only a minimum of easy to carry
portable equipment
no more on each trip than needed for the
case at hand
[Music]
by properly positioning the patient at
the side of a hospital bed
or with a portable backrest on a regular
bed and placing the hand equipment on a
table found in the patient's own room
ease and convenience of operation is
assured for this case note that the
dentist is using a portable high-speed
air turbine
powered by a small bottle of co2
who are the chronically ill they can be
simply defined as people with long-term
disabling
illnesses including arthritis diabetes
multiple sclerosis
heart disease palsy and many other
diseases
[Music]
most chronically ill and aged people can
with assistance visit the clinic or
office for dental treatment
in such cases with regular office
equipment and the dentist's own dental
assistant
there are only minor differences between
treating most chronically ill patients
and routine patients
with patients who cannot visit an office
or clinic the need for portable
equipment is obvious
to help dentists meet the needs of such
patients portable equipment was studied
along with other aspects of dental care
for the chronically ill in a four-year
research program by the united states
public health service
the study disclosed that complete and
satisfactory dental care can be given in
the home
with various types of currently
available portable equipment
for example this completely
self-contained luggage case unit
weighing less than 40 pounds
and powered from a standard 110 volt
wall outlet
includes a standard speed motor
aspirator compressed air
water spray and gooseneck lamp such
units have wide versatility
in this case the unit is supplemented by
a headrest that can be clamped on an
ordinary chair
the dentist takes with him on home calls
only a minimum of instruments and
supplies
carried in any handy carrying case that
can be laid out conveniently on a small
table found in the patient's own home
this is a typical home care situation in
practically every instance by using
available furniture
equipment and instruments can be located
as conveniently as in office situations
the dentist knew in advance that this
patient would require local anesthesia
so disposable cartridge and needle were
included in the kit of instruments for
this call
as in the office the dental assistant
acts as a second pair of hands for the
dentists
helping reduce the time required to
treat the patient
all that remains now is the preliminary
trimming of the restoration
and of course polishing at the next
visit
the completed restoration is fully
comparable to work done with standard
office equipment
total time elapsed from setting up to
leaving the house 30 minutes
only slightly longer than the office
time for similar work
[Music]
other types of dental treatment can be
provided equally well in the home
in this case the dental hygienist is
completing a prophylaxis with portable
equipment
that clamps directly to the wheelchair
headrest motor and gooseneck lamp
after the prophylaxis she will show the
patient how to brush his teeth properly
and suggest dietary considerations to
help him maintain
good dental health
at a later visit the dentist comes
prepared for an extraction with just the
equipment and instruments required
the headrest is clamped on the
wheelchair and for convenience in this
instance
the dentist uses a headlight instead of
a clamp-on gooseneck light
[Music]
the needed sterile instruments are laid
out on a table found in the patient's
room
alongside the aspirator that's plugged
into a wall outlet
the assistant removes blood and moisture
with a portable surgical aspirator
as in office chairside assisting
after the extraction the used
instruments are carefully wrapped and
put in the carrying case for returns of
the office where they will be sterilized
again the entire procedure has been
little different from office methods
except for the use of the minimum of
portable equipment required for the
visit
[Music]
the full range of dental treatment is
possible in home care cases
this patient has had 12 extractions
alveoloplasty
impressions and vertical and centric
records while confined to her bed
a hospital-type bed as is the case with
many long-term chronically ill patients
on this visit her dentures will be
inserted
dentures are important to this patient
for more than health reasons
most people confined by chronic illness
greatly need the lift attention gives
them
the feeling that somebody cares the
pleasure of eating a variety of foods
in addition the dentures will do much to
restore her self-confidence
and help her enjoy the company of her
family and friends
the equipment for adjusting her dentures
is simple in this case the dentures are
relieved with a standard stone in a
portable hand motor too
and to achieve proper occlusion the
tooth surfaces are ground and polished
with the same motor tool
using a standard dental wheel
each step in the making of this
patient's dentures was performed in her
home
extractions impressions bite
registration and of course
fitting of the completed dentures
prosthetics extractions restorations
oral surgery periodontal treatment
a complete range of dental care can be
administered to the chronically ill
in their homes with only slight
modification of the operating techniques
used in the office
where then are the differences primarily
in the management of the patient
and in evaluating her dental needs
whether the patient is in her home or
more commonly in the dentist's own
office or in the clinic
dental care is generally a special event
to the chronically ill
good rapport can usually be obtained by
making the patient feel the appointment
is a special event for the dentist too
[Music]
the chronically ill and aged often have
a lower tolerance to pain and discomfort
by allowing patients to rest frequently
and breaking up the treatment into
shorter periods undue fatigue and
tension can be avoided
it is also important to bolster the
patient's confidence
complementing her generously on each
accomplishment this approach is
applicable of course to any patient
of any age group
however younger chronically ill patients
are often more conscious of the extra
effort the dentist must make to treat
them
and therefore more obviously
appreciative
but no matter what the patient's age the
reassurance that the dentist personally
cares enough to provide the treatments
helps lighten the heavy emotional burden
of chronic illness
many chronically ill patients will also
be receiving medical treatment
and the dentist may wish to consult with
a patient's physician
it is important to have at least a brief
medical history so the need for
consultation can be judged
[Music]
a typical medical history should include
medical diagnosis of the patient's
illness
medication and the name of the patient's
physician
with general questions covering fainting
excessive bleeding
reactions from penicillin or anesthetics
sores that heal slowly and
other general symptoms that might
require consultation
[Music]
medical consultation is indicated
particularly for heart patients
or for patients on anticoagulant drugs
when extractions
are required
patients receiving corticosteroids for
conditions such as rheumatoid arthritis
ulcerative colitis or a blood dyscrasia
may be susceptible to post-operative
infections
for such patients prophylactic use of
antibiotics may be indicated
[Music]
medical consultation is usually
necessary for diabetic patients before
even minor dental procedures so routine
but necessary precautions may be taken
although most patients can be treated in
the office or home
hospitalization is sometimes required
for patients with severe circulatory
diseases
diabetes and extensive oral malignancies
criteria for treatment must be evaluated
along with several other aspects of the
patient's condition
one such factor is the patient's general
physical health for
example when long-term systemic
disorders have lowered general
resistance
dentures may cause deterioration of the
oral mucosa and tissues
in other patients periodontal disease
may have reduced supporting bone
structures so that denture success is
questionable
severe periodontal disease is not
uncommon with the chronically ill and
aged
since their oral hygiene is often poorly
maintained
the psychological attitude of the
patient is very important
[Music]
if the patient has adjusted well to
chronic illness as this patient has
his positive attitude may override many
adverse indications
the most important consideration is the
potential benefit to the patient
as can be seen the portable equipment is
light enough for easy handling
the responsibility for providing the
chronically ill engaged with dental care
falls on the entire community it is
shared by the aged and chronically ill
who must make an effort to obtain
care
it is shared by the dentist who must be
prepared to treat the chronically ill
and aged
it is shared by the professional schools
that must prepare future dentists and
hygienists
to treat the chronically ill as a
routine part of dental practice
whether in the office or in the home
the university of kansas city school of
dentistry for example
participated in the public health
service study of dental care for the
chronically ill
the classroom training of dental and
dental hygiene students was supplemented
by practice in private
and nursing homes
the result dental care for many people
who otherwise would not have been
treated
and training for the students in
situations significantly different from
the clinic or standard dental office we
asked dr hamilton bg robinson dean of
the school of dentistry at the
university of kansas city
for his evaluation of the training
program dr
robinson our dental students
and our dental hygiene students have
both benefited greatly from this program
they used the portable equipment they
learned to handle the patients
and above all they learned the great
need
that these patients have for dental care
in cooperation with the public health
service
we are incorporating treatment of the
chronically ill
and aged in the curricula of our dental
and dental hygiene schools
this means expanding our present courses
in home care
and may involve auxiliary training
centers at nursing homes
willing to cooperate with us
other dental schools of course are
working on similar plans
and we would like to feel that within
the next five or six years
every new dentist and every new dental
hygienist
will enter practice prepared to take
care of the chronically ill and aged
and that they will also expect that they
will have patients
who require complete dental care in
their own homes
in the meantime it remains for the
dentists of today to add a new dimension
to their general practice of dentistry
many of the chronically ill and aged fit
into normal office routine
the kansas city project and other
studies reached several clear
conclusions
among them the chronically ill and aged
can be treated at home
or in the office with no highly
specialized training
and with only slight modification of
operating techniques treatment criteria
and equipment management of such
patients requires a heightened
sensitivity to the patient
as an individual
assistance can of course help speed the
dentist work in both home
and office treatment
the dental hygienist can perform
prophylaxis give oral hygiene
instruction
and devise adaptations and modifications
of standard devices that enable the
patient to maintain better oral hygiene
[Music]
most types of treatment can be
administered either in the office or
home
when there is a choice treatment should
be given in a dental office or clinic
but sometimes there is no choice and the
dental service must be taken to the
patient
home care patients can be given the same
complete dental care as office patients
using portable equipment such equipment
might be obtained by the local dental
society health department or other
agencies
for the use of all dentists
[Music]
although dental care for the chronically
ill and aged may involve a little extra
time and effort
it yields a deep and rewarding
satisfaction for the burden of chronic
illness and age is a burden of
loneliness and isolation
filled with problems and worries
unfamiliar to most of us
lack of dental care should not be one of
these worries
it is not only practical and feasible to
provide the aged and chronically ill
with dental care
it is the ethical and moral obligation
of the dental profession
[Music]
you